y vamos a resolver este problema de
perímetro aquí nos pone en una figura
delimitada en azul y nos preguntan cuál
es el perímetro de la figura vamos a
contar es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
entonces el perímetro sería 22 también
pudimos haberlo pensado como la suma de
los lados dos más uno más uno más dos
más uno más tres más 432 más tres y eso
también nos daría 22 vamos a darle
comprobar respuesta muy bien vamos a
hacer otros más nos dicen cuál es el
perímetro del rectángulo y nos pone en
este rectángulo de aquí como es un
rectángulo este lado omite lo mismo que
este lado 5 y 5 son 10 este lado mide lo
mismo que este lado 6 y 6 son 12 los 10
que teníamos con esos 12 son 22 y
entonces el perímetro del rectángulo
sería 22 pies
le damos comprobar muy bien uno más cual
es el perímetro del triángulo aquí nos
dan las medidas de los lados del
triángulo que serían 6 4 y 5
basta sumarlas para encontrar el
perímetro 64 son 10 y 10 más 5 son 15
entonces el perímetro sería 15 pulgadas
muy bien